[Musica]
vediamo come vivo la bella tutti ragazzi
e per questo nuovo video sono parte oggi
sono su fight club che è un gioco tipo
non credo ci siano giochi tipo però
siccome sono sicuro che sto gioco c'è la
prossimo io andiamo su offline match e
facciamo c'è praticamente ragazzi e un
tekken con i granchi e beh allora io
l'ho scaricato che non hanno consigliato
è veramente la cosa più trash che io
abbia mai leggere la selezione del
personaggio puoi scegliere in diversi
tipi di granchi anche l'asti cielo bene
lo sa ragazzi sembrano mai detto ma è il
granchio mi fa c'è un senso e buona
mangiare ma da vedere mi fa schifo
perché siamo col ragno e quindi andrei
di evan segno questo qua per mad crepe
contro long arm e crepe
puoi anche ad aggiungere l'arma va bene
ok allora io metterei col piede di porco
lui e con la spada fortissima io vescovo
dire che puoi averne due
oh mio dio puoi avere una foca come arma
ognuno alle proprie statistiche
bellissimo ed essere pronto farti ring
ma come si gioca spiegatemi siamo
sott'acqua ho lasciato l'alabarda perché
mi fido veloce come si gioca non so che
appaia che vale porco demonio dolore
guardai non so non mi spiegano vi si
gioca l'ho presa lavarda l'ho presa
menaye mena lo non sapere che cosa sto
facendo
e devo colpirlo e basta c'è perché non
ho ben capito il senso lo devo colpire e
basta ok quindi girati girati dall'altra
parte è donna vista di troppo vicino
aiuto ai x mod
e vabbè sono andate in ai x mod vena lo
meno che sei mai fermo sono
incazzatissimo non so non ho capito ma
piccolo che va bene ok adesso io sono
davanti lui dietro la barba l'ho persa
perché sono in hyper moda adesso c'è
anche lui nei per mondo scappa scappa
aia ai ragazzi la iper mode proprio
prodotto
devo farlo arrivare a 100 per cento
immagini sono in vantaggio io adesso per
pochissimo ecco come non mi ha attirato
un attacco che veramente camerale up o
compagna re solo dai prendi alabarda che
stabilì per terra dai sono cento circa
venti sono morti
ama la vita non è quella a di rimandare
proprio ko l'avversario che vi penso
fosse la vita quella ok allora scherzavo
numerato capo ii o no amici e lui la
vinci lui lo andato ko non so come ho
fatto
la vince lui il professionista di
obbligo rischiato gioco prova ragazzi a
fare i due contro due questa è una roba
molto difficile
metto allora cambiamo personaggio di
prima mi piaceva fino al top ho scelto
ragazzi l'aragosta con le mazze chiodate
perché voglio provare a fare un due
contro due
i miei compagni sono allora al 3 agosto
a noi prendiamo lui e gli altri due li
mettiamo la mettiamo i due accusati 21
però anche loro non a me
armi se non ha senso perfetto andiamo lì
ventaglio che non so cosa possa servire
prova bene e dall'altro dimetterei gli
shuriken va bene sono veramente
contentissimo ragazzi fiero di questo
gameplay c'è una foca gigante amico mio
arrivo
vado mazze chiodate questo non ci fosse
un domani non vedo più niente
e successo a ya c'è una foca enorme
menaye la poca mena la mela tutto che
ammucchiata incredibile ragazzine mazze
chiodate sono fortissime mena tutto no
lo perse lo perse guanciali jolie che da
ragazzi difficilissimo da xavi a da xavi
ha via via via l'astice di elastici
aiuto qualcuno si sta sull trasformando
i super sayan là dietro aiuto e la
madonna cioè lo gestisci tu hai a che
male da poco è fortissima non ho capito
se colpendo la poca in qualche modo non
ho capito se colpendo la poca in qualche
modo posso fare del danno però con sopra
stein ai x mod di roberto stato poi ci
finisco anche io proprie che mi ha
[ __ ] le no il mio compagno no amico
mio non è vero mi hai lasciato da solo
contro sti due pie schifo ma fai schifo
ma inizialmente battere da solo aiuto
ragazzi non vale il mio compagno faceva
vomitare ai x mod gol ad agosto si sta
cappottando ragazzi uno per volta riesco
a finir di magari posso rifarlo
questo di animare il mio amico fermi al
dottor indietro fammelo rianimare fame
lorìa di vara fermi tutti
maledizione dov'è il mio amico non lo
vedo più è veramente difficile ragazzi
cioè il gioco con più comandi della
storia cioè veramente ci vole un'ora per
fare una mossa
ok lascia in avanti dietro dove dove sta
il mio compagno con la trovata cosa
trovato il ventaglio maledizione non
riesco a restarlo ecco ecco veloce ce
l'ha fatta ce l'ho fatta e remote vai
dai 6 dai per modo c'è anche il mio
compagno che di nuovo vivo perfetto
ragazzi siamo in un garage a comunicare
allora è stato eccolo la toga paolo in
orologi del originato dalla parte giusta
praticamente ragazzi è un mix di giochi
o mix tra dark souls e smash non è vero
non è vero cina sigillati citati sono
vivo a posto a posto stava per buttarmi
giù ma non ce l'ha fatta
maledizione girati di nuovo girati vivo
oggi ha di nuovo a girarmi sono
fantastico a giocare un po meno ai 240
prendi botta mi girano dall'altra parte
questa volta finita da fare che lui
porta c'è il mio compagno ma è morto di
nuovo quell'altro ma che schifo
no vabbè ragazzi a temi dei compagni
decenti per cortesia datemi le coop tu
sei forte non come gli altri o
completamente randomizzato tutto va bene
kocon out club rai e il granchio del
cocco il granchio della neve
io sono il granchio peloso
ragazzi lo stiamo ammazzando passiamo
veramente bollendo nell'acqua putrida
contro è morto veloce compagno spacca lo
sono già tutti in dieci secondi sunrise
beast però ragazzi lo stiamo facendo un
danno devastante molto qui come a posto
come non detto
morto sono morto io sono stato un
secondo prendi una roba per terra
schifoso premi lo se mi accompagnano non
è il mio compagno questo spaccato
perfetto 21 a prosto come lui el'altro
dov'è finito
raga non ho capito che che è successo
all'altro favi cambiare il granchio per
favore mi fa schifo
dovete prendere uno tipo strappo eccolo
madonna molto sul grosso pavan host sono
lento come la morte ma sono grossissimo
perfetto ma vedi che l'arbitro si
rompono in un assenso averla cioè si
puoi averla ma dovunque si scavano in
italia c'è un missile
c'è uno che ha un missile non vale come
ha trovato un missile quello ragazzi si
e non vale però è troppo forte
stasera sta succedendo aiuto e mappe
vedo ragni con i missili che volano essi
grant i ragazzi a me viene da di ragni
perché mi sembra veramente radice fanno
schifo i granchi infatti non lo mangio
mai perché mi fa
ma giuro
sto scherzando non riesco a mangiare un
asino ragazzi sua 202 come mi toccano
sono parto per la troposfera quindi via
ok l'avversario è un dato gravissimo
siamo in due io faccio schifo ma
possiamo ancora farcela ma come you lose
siamo due contro uno contro uno ma
finite voi ma allora come sta storia che
se muoio io perdiamo e se muore un
avversario no cioè spiegami non ha senso
due enormi contro due anni però io c'ho
il martello vada mela col martello bravo
schiacciata di aragosta oggi veramente
la ricostruzione della frode
il battello leva un casino abbiamo
appurato questo il problema che faccio
mi sta mettendo alle corde
forse ragazzi menare insistentemente
l'avversario non è una gran fatica
perché poi vai subito in snai x mod per
pezzo perfetto
guarda come messo all'angolo all'angolo
rocky balboa bravo
mamma mia che forte lo meritavamo
fortissimo mi rimane uno meno è andato a
terra cosa terra figlioli tienilo fermo
kilju fermo
non sarò un pro gamer di quake di porno
però la mia qualità e indiscutibile
signori spero che questo gioco vi sia
per questo era tekken però fatto bene
spero che vi sia piaciuto è stato il
momento più bello della mia vita ho
speso 20 euro per questo giorno lasciato
un bel ai kiss criteri al canale
cliccate anche la campanella le
notifiche per rimanere aggiornati sui
nuovi video chiesto e noi come sempre ci
vediamo hanno una prossima battaglia di
granchi e aragoste quella roba lì bella
ragazza
[Musica]